candace owens has been watching all of
this and analyzing what it means for a
long time she's hosted the canis owens
podcast we're happy to have her candace
i mean these videos are getting more and
more extreme
they're not performances they're real
it's americans who are being targeted
and suffering and killed
why is no one saying anything about this
well first and foremost tucker you
mentioned kim fox in chicago and i just
want to say what you forgot to mention
is the fact that she's both black and a
female and also the mayor of chicago is
black and a female so i just want to
introduce that because you know
diversity and equity and inclusion and
fluffy words that are supposed to make
you feel good even though they're doing
bad before they introduce the bait and
the switch it's infuriating to watch
your monologue it's infuriating to watch
the monologue look at all the crime look
at the statistics and look at the laws
behind it because you know what it makes
me think you know what it makes the
american people think the criminals are
on the streets but the worst criminals
are in office they're voting on pieces
of legislation they're pushing pushing
through pieces of policies that are
harming the american people and they
know it's harming the american people
thing is they just don't care because
they have armed guards because they live
behind gated communities because they've
sold out the american people we all knew
this was going to come we voted these
people into office by the way these are
elected officials that stood on a
platform and told you to defund the
police because they had armed guards
they didn't care of course we're seeing
this consequence we all saw it coming
you spoke about it i spoke about it we
were saying it ad nauseam guys please be
aware the black lives matter narrative
is a complete and utter lie and by the
way who is being harmed the most it's
everybody it doesn't matter what your
race is or your ethnicity or your gender
but who's being harmed the absolute most
when you look at the numbers of course
it's black americans the very people
that they purported to help when they
had first pushed out these policies oh
don't worry it's going to be great don't
worry about it we're going to defund the
police like i said it's infuriating i do
want to say this to people that are
watching are still living in these inner
communities in democrat cities get out
this is not a joke don't wait for it to
be you don't wait for it to be your
child that you're pushing in a stroller
when you get run over don't wait for it
to be you that's going for a jog down
the street and you're grabbed into a van
and killed and you have two kids and
you're my age like what happened to
eliza fletcher in memphis do not wait
for politicians to rescue you rescue
yourself and get out of these democrat
controlled cities
i think that's really good advice
kenneth owens i appreciate you coming
out tonight thank you subscribe to the
fox news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight